Hey what you working on?
>> Yeah, I'm having some
trouble deciding what to do
about the Udacity app rewrite.
>> Ooh, are you going to rewrite
the Udacity app in Swift?
>> You know,
I do code more quickly in Swift, but
rewriting the entire app
would be a lot of work.
On the other hand, I don't really want
to write new features in Objective C.
>> Did someone say Objective C?
Objective C is so dynamic.
Doesn't make you feel like you
have more power as a developer?
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> But Swift is a more
modern concise language and
it probably improve performance.
>> Yeah, that's true too.
The more I think about it,
I think the best move might
be to try to use them both.
>> Hmm, but Objective C and
Swift are so different.
How are we going to get
them talking to each other?
>> [MUSIC]
>> You say, inum and I say, inam.
You say, dynamic and I say, static.
Inum, inam, dynamic, static,
let's call the whole thing off.
You say, giffy and I say, jiffy.
You call a function and I say a message.
Giffy, jiffy, function, message,
let's call the whole thing off.
>> But, if we call the whole thing off.
>> You lose foundation.
>> And if we ever part,
then that might break my app.
[MUSIC]
So if I liked type arrays and
you liked untyped,
I'll take them untyped
with optional casting, for
we know we need each other so
we better call the calling off, off.
Let's master.
>> You say, care.
>> And you say, car.
>> I like to swizzle.
>> And I do not swizzle.
>> Care.
>> Car.
>> Swizzle.
>> No swizzling.
>> Let's call the whole thing off.
[MUSIC]
But if we call the whole thing
off- You'd loose core data.
And if we ever part then
that might break my app.
So if I pass you value,
would you want some warning?
>> You can use annotations.
>> For we know we need each other so
we better call the calling off, off.
Let's master.
>> [BLANK_AUDIO]